[Music]
for the 45.3 million American households
with a cat the anoints of scooping cat
litter is a daily one and pet owners are
Big Spenders pen industry sales reach
124 billion dollars in 2021 according to
the American Pet Products Association
that spending combined with the
popularity of Robot vacuum cleaners and
the acceptance of technology in our
homes has led to a growing business for
michigan-based whisker Revenue reached
nearly 180 million dollars last year a
24-fold increase from 2015 7.5 million
and it all began in the basement of
whisker founder Brad Baxter
I have to go back over 20 years back to
1998. now at this point I had decided
that I wanted to go into business for
myself I wanted to start an Engineering
Services product development services
company and I ended up doing that and
while I had some success with that I
realized that what I really wanted to do
is I wanted to invent I wanted to build
a company around that invention and at
the time I didn't really know what that
was I was working on a few different
things at the time you know
experimenting exploring but really
hadn't found that aha moment that set me
on the right path a year later after
starting that business that opportunity
actually came in the form of two cats
and an overflowing litter box I was down
in my basement cleaning up kitty litter
mess because when my cats had a dirty
litter box they wouldn't actually go in
the Box they would go outside of the box
and while I was doing that I was
thinking about ways that I could somehow
automate the process because I was just
sick and tired of having to scoop the
litter box what I was thinking about was
really some kind of a rotational sifting
device using gravity to our advantage
instead of raking through the litter and
pushing clumps and it was you know that
was a fairly inefficient process and I
thought the next step really is to start
to do a patent search
so when I went ahead did a patent search
and found something very similar to what
I was already doing
and instead of abandoning the idea or
the dream of pursuing this product I
decided I would contact the inventor and
see if we could work out a license
agreement which is exactly what we did
[Music]
I was in California demonstrating the
very first litter robot in April of
2001. the early days were actually
pretty difficult there was no funding my
parents actually refinanced their home
so that they could provide thirty five
thousand dollars which was what the
tooling cost to get this off the ground
and so my dad became a partner in the
business he owned 35 percent of the
business at the time and that was really
my first source of funding after that
there was no external funding Banks were
not going to touch me with a 10-foot
pole because there really wasn't any
collateral
so I had to find a way to make it work
and the other business that I had
started in 1998 which was an Engineering
Services business and I kept that
running for almost 20 years and it was
that business for the first five years
of starting automated pet care that
other business kept automated Pet Care
alive I was able to funnel all my
profits from the automotive business
back into the pet care business
there were a lot of challenges early on
because this was really a new segment of
product and although there was one other
product on the market the way I was
doing it was quite different and there
were a lot of things that we learned
about safety making sure that the
appliance is safe for the cat there were
a lot of learning experiences there
there was a lot of
experiences and lessons learned about
running a business especially without
external funding it made it very
difficult I actually had to retool the
product at about the fifth year in in
order to take cost out to make it more
efficient so that we could actually
start making a profit once we started
making a profit I was able to reinvest a
lot of that money back into marketing
and then we started to see real growth
after that
in 2015 Jacob zubke came on as a
consultant to help whisker with its
marketing a Serial entrepreneur Zuki was
asked by an old friend to help the PEC
goods company with their digital
marketing he built such a good
relationship with Baxter that he stayed
on and became CEO in 2022
[Music]
in 2015 when I joined the company I saw
a really cool opportunity where the
company had a phenomenal product was
about to launch a new version of the
product and maybe lacked a little bit on
the marketing front I know I can poke
some fun at Brad there and he won't be
offended but if you do way back machine
and you take a look at our 2015 website
I think you'll see there was a lot of
room for improvement as a marketer I saw
this really cool opportunity where the
reviews were just insanely cool I
remember reading one specific review of
a woman who said that it saved her
marriage because her then fiance did not
want a cat in the home and the only way
he would tolerate it is with a little
robot and I remember reading that at the
time not having a cat and saying I can
tell this story and I can do something
with this and my big aha moment was at
the end of 2015 as we got ready to
launch the litter robot 3. I lined up
what was at the time called social
celebrities and we had 25 social
celebrities lined up and each day in
December they would give away a little
robot at the time our previous record
traffic was about 35 000 visits to our
website in one month on December 1st
alone we had 35 000 website visits and
it was an aha moment for me and I
carried that into 2016 where we ended up
growing by over 80 percent that year and
we continued to double down and double
down
one of the things I had a misconception
about was marketing I felt that if I
built the greatest product that they
would all come running for it and I
wouldn't have to really spend all that
much on marketing and that word of mouth
would take over that is not the case
marketing is something that you have to
constantly invest in you have to
constantly adjust and adapt because
everything is changing in the
marketplace all the time I didn't
realize this early on but as I started
investing in marketing I realized that
that is some it's you know it's a very
important component of what of what we
do and it's something that you have to
constantly adapt and change and modify
and so the more money we made the more
we put into marketing and IT you know
the results of that were and the success
of that are what really sold me on
taking that approach with marketing
at the end of 2017 you started to see
the landscape change a little bit and at
that time we really pivoted the
television so in 2018 we shot our big
big first commercial called don't be a
scooper and it was our way of poking fun
at people that were still scooping we
almost made it a negative term to be a
scooper
it was an aha moment for the company how
do we tell a story about how this litter
box can truly change your life and how
the thing of the past is not the thing
of the future and it was a really cool
moment for us where we really saw the
direct correlation between putting out a
spot that helped people see the litter
box differently and the goal of that
spot when we set out to go on our
creative Retreat and write that spot
together was we want somebody who's
previously scooped to never be able to
look at the litter box the same again
and to remember this spot the next time
they're elbow deep in cat news and
that's exactly what we came out of it
with and I think ever since then we've
tried to find creative moments of
telling our story different and breaking
through the noise in the Clutter of what
is advertising
it's been great working with Jacob I
think the key to us working together is
that we are very different he is a very
very much a people person open I like to
call him the glue within the company
he's also very Adept at walking into her
room distilling the situation and
figuring out kind of what the next steps
are I think that's very important for a
leader we complement each other because
I'm a lot more focused and tactical
operations engineering focused I really
get into problem solving I'm spending a
lot of time with focused work where it's
you know it's a different way of working
and as the company has grown there's
been a greater need for let's call it
that glue that Jacob provides in his
role we work together very well and we
have a mutual respect for each other
[Music]
with the direct to Consumer business
growing they move to a 30 000 square
foot factory in Juneau Wisconsin in
2008. since then they've expanded the
factory to 225 000 square feet
[Music]
so in 2015 when I joined the company I
remember Brad telling me that in 2009
when he bought the property that we're
still in today that he was going to tarp
off half of the building to rent it out
to somebody else
and fast forward to 2023 we have now
done several expansions of our
facilities investing as much as 13
million dollars into our Juno Wisconsin
location here proudly manufacturing our
robots here in America that's allowed us
to go from 30 000 square feet to 60 000
in 2020 2021 and then we did another
expansion in 2021 2022 that carried us
from sixty thousand to two hundred and
twenty two thousand square feet today
that allows us to employ over 300
employees here in Juneau Wisconsin for a
total of 500 in our company
that allows us to keep up with consumer
demand and will allow us to grow into
what will be nearly a million robots a
year here in our Factory in Wisconsin
for us manufacturing here in the United
States is important and actually it's
it's a good business decision really I
mean because we make a fairly large
product and to have this product made
overseas brought over on a boat stored
in a warehouse and then shipped to the
customers I mean
there's a lot of expense in the supply
chain and actually shipping the product
over from some other offshore suppliers
so
from early on we decided we were going
to locate our manufacturing close to our
suppliers and we we identified our
plastic suppliers here in Wisconsin and
we decided to locate the plant here for
that reason so that we we would be close
to the supply of parts so all we were
doing is integrating the actual assembly
process into the where you know with the
warehousing of the product and the
Fulfillment side of things
and it just made a lot of sense to be
vertically integrated
[Music]
when I think about what makes whisker
magical it's really it's our inventive
culture we have a lot of people that are
super passionate about building the
future of pet care and they get to bring
that inventiveness and their tenacity to
work every single day whether you are in
our operations facility where you are
working on the line and you're saying I
have an idea and I think I can make this
process a little bit better
or you're in our engineering lab in
Michigan working on a new inventive
product that may redefine a new category
in Pet Care in the future the goal of
what we're trying to do is bring a lot
of very creative people to whisker to
help bring their best selves to work
every day and really helps help us shape
the future of pet care
I've been at whisker now for 23 years
and whisker is completely ingrained in
me I mean this whisker is a part of my
life this is this was a vision I had
over 23 years ago and I was
told many times that this would never go
anywhere that it was not suitable for
retail
but I stuck with it and I think our
success is what shows that it was you
know the right decision to stick with it
at the time and I think for for me
whisker is evolving a great deal and I'm
very excited to see what we're going to
do in the future with our our digital
products and our apps and what we can do
with the data that we collect from all
the hardware and how we how we integrate
that into a holistic view of the uh the
pet wellness that's what I'm really
excited about is is the data side as
well as the great Hardware that we can
couple with that
[Music]
thank you